Musique de tension
Voilà, j'y arrive pas.
-Les Français n'ont jamais été
aussi malheureux au travail.
44 % d'entre eux s'estiment
en état de détresse psychologique.
Plus de deux tiers seraient stressés
par leur emploi.
-On devient dingues.
Trop d'emails, trop de...
Trop de réunions.
-Conséquence de dizaines d'années
où il a fallu gagner
en productivité.
-C'est le toujours plus,
avec toujours moins de salariés
et de moyens.
*-Les gens qui souffrent
de leur travail,
ils font face
à des objectifs inatteignables.
-Instauration du télétravail,
dislocation des équipes...
La crise sanitaire a accentué
le mal-être.
-Ce qui donne sens a changé.
Il y a un avant et un après Covid.
-Alors, que disent les gens
qui souffrent au travail ?
Comment prévenir les risques ?
Sommes-nous arrivés
au bout d'un système ?
-Moi, j'attends le "boum".
J'attends. Je suis convaincue
que ça finira par venir.
...
-Quand on parle
de souffrance au travail,
il faut d'abord citer un fait :
la France détient le sombre record
du plus grand nombre
d'accidents du travail
en Europe,
plus de 630 000 par an,
deux fois plus que la moyenne
des pays européens.
Dans son cabinet
de médecine du travail...
-Allez-y, entrez.
-...Marielle Dumortier reçoit
ces salariés blessés.
-Asseyez-vous.
-Ce matin,
il s'agit d'une responsable
d'un magasin de meubles
qui, après un arrêt de travail
de plusieurs mois,
fait une visite de pré-reprise.
-L'accident du travail,
c'était quand ?
-Le 11 août 2020.
-Qu'est-ce qui vous êtes arrivé ?
-Je suis tombée dans les escaliers
de la réserve.
-D'accord.
Du coup, vous êtes tombée,
vous vous êtes pas arrêtée,
j'imagine ?
-J'ai... Oui.
Je me suis accrochée à mon travail.
-Voilà, parce que ?
-Parce qu'il y avait besoin.
J'ai eu du mal
à quitter le navire
et à me prendre en charge.
C'est la douleur
qui n'était plus possible,
plus tenable.
Je ne dormais plus.
Je souffrais.
Mon bras ne fonctionnait
absolument plus.
Il fallait agir.
-Les études montrent
que les travailleurs français
sont des bons professionnels
qui aiment leur métier.
Vous en êtes encore
une illustration. Voilà.
-J'en suis la preuve.
-Même quand on a mal, on y va.
-C'est ça.
C'est ça.
-En France, plus d'un tiers
des salariés travaillent
alors qu'ils sont malades.
Marielle Dumortier a bien du mal
à faire entendre raison
à sa patiente.
-J'ai repris jeudi,
pour l'instant,
j'ai pas repris la kiné.
-Moi, je pense
que reprendre à temps plein,
ce que vous avez fait,
c'est pas forcément une bonne idée.
Moi, je vous encourage vraiment
à faire un mi-temps thérapeutique.
C'est compliqué,
dans votre fonction ?
-Ca va pas être gérable.
-Parce que ?
-On ne trouve pas de personnel...
Je ne suis pas irremplaçable,
mais j'ai précisé
que je reprenais à temps complet,
j'ai repris à temps complet,
je ne me vois pas dire maintenant :
"Finalement, non,
je ne reprends qu'à mi-temps."
-Donc, je marque :
"Peut reprendre le travail
sur un poste aménagé,
à condition de ne pas faire
de manutention manuelle
"supérieure à 5 kilos.
"Ne doit pas travailler
bras en l'air."
Avec une belle faute...
-Douleurs aux épaules,
douleurs au dos ou au poignet,
des pathologies regroupées
sous le nom
de "troubles musculo-squelettiques",
des TMS,
la maladie professionnelle
la plus répandue chez les Français.
Cette dame vient
pour une simple visite de routine,
mais très vite,
la docteure Dumortier va constater
qu'elle est usée
par le travail.
Musique intrigante
...
-Vous travaillez, là ?
Vous faites le ménage à l'hôpital ?
Depuis combien de temps ?
-Depuis maintenant six ans.
Là-bas, c'est pas facile,
surtout...
Il y a beaucoup de boulot.
-Ouais. Ouais. Ouais.
Au niveau de votre santé,
il y a eu des choses nouvelles
depuis la dernière visite ?
-Maintenant, là,
j'ai mal à l'épaule.
-Ah, vous avez mal à l'épaule ?
-Ici, là.
-L'épaule gauche.
Et dans le dos,
vous avez mal aussi ?
-Des fois, j'ai mal au dos.
-Port de charges trop lourdes,
gestes répétitifs...
Contrairement aux idées reçues,
les TMS touchent plus les femmes
que les hommes.
-Tendez bien les bras.
Vous les mettez bien comme ça.
Vous allez résister
à ce que je vais faire.
Vous résistez...
Non, vous faites les bras durs.
Vous résistez, vous résistez...
Résistez...
Je vous fais mal, là ?
-Oui, là.
-De ce côté ?
Allez, encore le bras dur.
Je vais les monter, vous résistez.
Vous savez, il va falloir
que vous mettiez
votre bras au repos, madame.
Vous avez une inflammation
au niveau des tendons
et des muscles de l'épaule.
Si vous tardez trop,
si vous tirez trop
sur cette épaule,
vous allez l'abîmer,
et après, ce sera encore
beaucoup plus compliqué pour vous.
Je sais, vous vous attendiez
pas du tout à ça, aujourd'hui.
Pour vous, c'est un petit choc.
Bon. Vous avez 58 ans.
Il faut faire attention
à vous, madame.
-Dans son cabinet,
la médecin voit de plus en plus
de salariés souffrant de TMS
dès 50 ans
et s'interroge au moment
où le report du départ à la retraite
rallonge encore les carrières.
-La majorité des emplois,
on est dans le toujours plus,
avec toujours moins
de salariés et de moyens.
Donc, du coup, il y a
une usure prématurée articulaire.
Il est temps de penser
aux conditions de travail.
Si on veut maintenir les gens
au travail plus longtemps,
pourquoi pas,
ça se justifie peut-être,
je n'ai pas d'avis à donner,
mais si on veut faire ça,
il faut faire de la prévention
dans les entreprises.
-Alors, certaines entreprises
prennent le sujet
à bras-le-corps.
Nous sommes chez l'un des leaders
du secteur du nettoyage,
des métiers où les cas de TMS
sont deux fois plus importants
que chez le reste des salariés.
-Bonjour. Enchanté.
-Ce jour-là, des médecins du travail
viennent constater
les mesures mises en place
depuis 2 ans pour prévenir les TMS.
-Je vous invite
à rentrer dans les sanitaires,
pour la première démonstration.
C'est parti.
Je vous en prie. Allez-y.
Donc, Sandra,
tu vas nous expliquer...
-Ca, c'était avant.
-Là, comme vous pouvez le constater
sur l'intervention de Sandra,
l'épaule est très sollicitée,
de droite à gauche.
C'est un effort physique
qui est quand même considérable.
Même les chevilles sont sollicitées
dans ce genre d'intervention.
En temps normal,
Sandra nettoie
une dizaine de sanitaires
par vacation.
Le fait de travailler matin et soir,
à la journée,
ça fait une vingtaine de sanitaires.
Une vingtaine de miroirs à nettoyer.
Forcément, ça a un impact
sur les articulations,
d'où la nécessité
de trouver des solutions
pour lutter contre les TMS.
-Mais avec l'introduction
d'outils bien pensés,
les gestes sont différents.
-Le salarié fait
moins d'efforts physiques,
comparé à avant.
-C'est les deux épaules
qui travaillent,
alors que j'ai remarqué qu'avant,
c'était une seule épaule.
-Voilà.
-C'est réparti différemment.
-Surtout les appuis,
au niveau du sol.
-L'idéal, aussi,
c'est d'alterner les tâches.
Quand il y a quelqu'un
qui fait essentiellement
ce type d'activité,
ça peut engendrer plus facilement
des TMS.
-Ca vous amène à réfléchir
à la conception
de votre fiche de poste,
aux tâches demandées...
-Exactement.
-L'arrivée de nouveaux accessoires
permet aussi
d'éviter les chutes.
-Il va tourner de cette façon.
On va chercher l'armoire.
C'est parti, Sandra.
-Dans une entreprise
où la moyenne d'âge est
de près de 50 ans
et où on peine à recruter,
les TMS sont un fléau.
-Beaucoup d'absences,
d'arrêts de travail,
et on fait des déclarations
de maladie professionnelle,
ce qui a un coût évidemment
pour l'entreprise également.
-Depuis la mise en place
de ces simples outils,
l'entreprise a vu
ses arrêts de travail baisser,
et son turnover réduit.
-Quand vous avez beaucoup
de personnes qui s'absentent,
forcément,
il faut les remplacer.
Remplacer quelqu'un
qui est titulaire d'un poste,
qui est formé,
c'est toujours compliqué.
La prestation ne sera jamais faite
de la même façon
qu'un titulaire.
L'agent travaille
dans de bonnes conditions
et on a moins de coûts,
comparé à des arrêts maladie
à répétition.
-C'est un bon investissement ?
-Même très bon.
Aujourd'hui,
on est très contents du programme,
et on compte pas
s'arrêter là.
-Mais depuis la crise sanitaire,
ces TMS ne sont plus
la première cause
d'arrêts de travail
de longue durée.
Ils ont été devancés
par des troubles psychologiques,
dus au travail.
L'Institut de veille sanitaire
chiffre à 30 000
le nombre de burn-outs
par an,
mais le ressenti est tout autre.
Selon le dernier baromètre
OpinionWay, sur la santé
psychologique des salariés,
30 % se disent au bord du burn-out.
Plus de deux tiers des salariés
disent subir un stress régulier.
-Installez-vous.
-Ce matin, c'est une manager
dans un cabinet de consulting
qui a demandé à être reçue
par la médecin du travail.
Elle n'en peut plus.
-J'ai pas mal de responsabilités.
Il faut que je réalise
les missions chez les clients.
A côté, il faut que je m'occupe
de recrutements,
de tous les appels d'offre,
soutenances, etc.,
j'ai de la gestion de carrière
à faire
sur une partie des consultants.
Plusieurs fois par semaine,
je m'effondre,
mais sur trois fois rien.
On va me demander :
"Contact Bidule
pour faire telle chose,
"ça prend 10 minutes."
Mais pendant deux heures,
minimum,
je me mets à pleurer
et je suis incapable
de faire quoi que ce soit.
J'y arrive pas.
-Est-ce que vous en avez parlé
à votre N+1 ?
-Il m'a dit :
"T'as choisi de faire du conseil,
"t'as choisi de travailler plus
pour gagner plus,
"donc il est normal de faire
des nocturnes, des week-ends."
Et depuis, j'ai arrêté de parler,
parce que ça a rompu le dialogue.
-Vous avez vu la DRH, madame ?
D'accord.
Ca va être la personne à voir.
Dans le code du travail,
celui qui est responsable
des conditions de travail,
de l'état de santé mentale
et physique des salariés,
c'est l'employeur.
Son représentant, le DRH,
doit être au courant.
Il faut pas que ça vous change,
il faut pas que ça change
votre manière de voir le travail,
vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
-Oui, je vois.
En vrai...
Enfin, il y a quand même...
Tout s'accélère.
On a besoin de faire toujours plus
avec plus de moyens.
Je le vois dans mon conseil
et aussi chez mes clients.
J'interviens au sein
d'un grand groupe,
les gens font des horaires
de malade,
ils vont avoir
des restrictions budgétaires,
les personnes qui partent
ne seront pas remplacées.
Pour autant, il faut pouvoir assurer
un meilleur positionnement
d'une entité au sein d'une boîte.
J'attends le boum.
Je suis convaincue que ça finira
par venir.
-Si cette jeune femme
est visiblement
surchargée de travail,
parfois, la pression
peut être plus insidieuse,
simplement due
à l'usage excessif
de la communication numérique.
-Les salariés sont submergés
par les mails.
Ca augmente la charge mentale.
Vous êtes en train de travailler,
vous êtes en réunion,
c'est un travail,
vous êtes train de travailler
sur un dossier,
et les mails continuent à arriver
les uns derrière les autres.
Parfois, c'est juste des mails
pour tenir au courant,
le fameux PI,
et le FYI,
"Pour ton information".
Ils sont noyés par les mails
et parfois,
des informations passent à l'as,
parce que vous avez 60 mails,
et vous avez loupé
celui qu'il fallait lire,
auquel il fallait réagir.
Surtout, ce que je ressens,
c'est une priorité
qui chasse l'autre priorité.
Une priorité
chasse l'autre priorité.
Ca, c'est une réalité.
-Sentiment d'urgence,
excès d'informations,
débordement du travail
dans la sphère personnelle,
l'hyperconnexion
engendre des risques.
C'est ce qu'a voulu mesurer
Arthur Vincent.
Il a créé un observatoire
de ce qu'il appelle
l'infobésité.
Alors, à chaque fois qu'il se rend
dans une entreprise...
-Bonjour, tout le monde.
-...il pose les mêmes questions.
Musique douce
-Ca va ?
-Oui, très bien.
Grosse journée ?
Beaucoup de mails à traiter ?
-Oui.
Un peu plus d'une cinquantaine.
-Arthur a recensé
qu'un cadre traite
entre 140 et 300 messages
par semaine.
Malgré le droit à la déconnexion
dicté dans une loi de 2017,
la journée de travail
se prolonge souvent à la maison.
-Même avec le smartphone,
t'arrives à pas reconnecter ?
-Ca dépend des jours.
Il y a des jours oui
et des jours non.
Lorsqu'on a une période
avec beaucoup de projets,
qu'on doit être présents
sur le terrain
ou qu'on a des évènements,
le soir, avec des événements
de rencontre avec des candidats,
oui, tu restes sur ton téléphone
pour avoir une vision
de ce qui se passe.
-Carrément.
-Dans cette grande entreprise
d'audits,
la DRH a conscience du problème.
-Bonjour, Mathilde.
-Ca va ?
-Très bien.
-Mais les chiffres de l'étude
la surprennent quand même.
-On est bien.
-Je découvrais le petit fascicule
avec les données.
-T'es contente des résultats ?
-Ca me fait flipper pour moi.
-Ca te fait réfléchir ?
-Ce volume toujours plus important
d'e-mails
n'est pas sans conséquences
sur la santé.
-Cette densité d'informations
et de sollicitation tout le temps,
ça rend dingue, en fait.
On est en train de devenir dingue,
trop d'e-mails, trop de réunions.
Clairement, nous,
on en mesure les...
Le stress numérique,
les effets sur la concentration,
ça, on le mesure.
On fait beaucoup
de baromètres sociaux.
On en parle,
on sait que c'est le point noir.
-Sur l'hyperconnexion,
on se rend compte
qu'il y a quasiment un tiers
des gens aujourd'hui qui,
plus de 50 soirs par an,
envoie des mails après le boulot.
C'est plus quelque chose
de négligeable.
Ca fait partie du quotidien,
maintenant.
-"Je traite mes e-mails le soir
parce que j'ai du temps."
A la limite, flexibilité, OK.
Les destinataires
vont les recevoir.
"C'est pas grave, je leur ai pas
demandé de réponse."
On oublie qu'il y a un lien
de subordination.
"Je reçois des e-mails
de mon manager
"le soir ou tôt le matin,
"si c'est pas explicité,
"je m'attends à ce qu'il attende
une réponse."
Pour beaucoup, ça va être :
"Il faut que je sois réactif,
il faut répondre."
Une injonction implicite
de faire quelque chose.
Et ça, démultiplié,
en fait, je pense que nos cerveaux,
nos corps,
- c'est déjà dans la tête -
ne sont pas faits pour intégrer
et être autant stimulés
intellectuellement
tout le temps
sur ce type de tâche.
-C'est exactement
les conséquences de ce fil
qu'on a tiré pendant 40 ans.
-Pour Arthur et sa collègue,
analyser la façon dont les mails
sont gérés
pourrait servir à repérer
un salarié en détresse.
-Des gens ont une stratégie :
"Zéro mails le soir".
En fin de journée,
il y a zéro mails à traiter
dans la boîte mail.
On peut voir que petit à petit,
quand on va vers un burn-out,
ça glisse.
Il va rester 10 mails,
puis 100 mails, puis 200 mails,
et en fait, on voit bien
qu'au bout d'un moment,
c'est exactement la définition
du stress.
Au bout d'un moment,
si on n'arrive plus à le traiter,
le stress devient trop important
et on finit par craquer.
Ca, nous,
on pense qu'à un moment,
on va justement pouvoir mesurer
les signaux faibles de ça
en fonction des habitudes
de travail des personnes.
-Sans compter que la crise sanitaire
a accentué le phénomène.
-Maintenant,
avec le travail à distance,
l'hybride, en fait,
on met plus du tout de limite
soi-même avec soi-même.
Même en tant qu'organisation,
il faut rappeler que là,
c'est la pause déjeuner.
-C'était un temps sacré
où on mettait pas de réunion.
Chacun s'est adapté
pendant le Covid,
il y avait plus le temps
pour tout faire,
et on voit dans les stats
que le temps de déjeuner
n'est plus une pause.
-Autre changement
dans les entreprises :
les équipes dirigeantes
et les organisations
sont de plus en fréquemment
renouvelées,
avec leur bataillon
de cadres intermédiaires,
qu'il faut faire craquer
coûte que coûte,
pour qu'ils quittent l'entreprise.
C'est ce qu'il s'est passé
pour celle
que nous appellerons Suzanne.
Après 20 ans
de bons et loyaux services
et un poste de manager,
la direction
de son entreprise change.
Elle se voit très vite convoquée.
-J'ai été reçue
par cette présidence.
Elle a remis en cause
un point très précis
de ma pratique professionnelle,
pour laquelle je n'avais jamais eu
de difficulté jusqu'à présent.
J'avais même,
de la part de l'externe,
une certaine reconnaissance
de qualité.
Il se trouve que cette présidence
avait tort sur le sujet même
de cette convocation.
J'ai pu apporter,
dans l'entretien,
une contradiction
qui n'a pas du tout plu
et qui n'est pas passée.
A partir de ce moment-là,
j'ai eu le sentiment
d'être la cible de quelque chose
que je ne cernais pas.
Petit à petit, mon équipe
était un...
en quelque sorte un outil
à la disposition de la gouvernance
pour m'atteindre,
pour me discréditer,
pour me démotiver,
et le tout,
avec un objectif
de me faire quitter
cette entreprise,
par une démission,
sans doute.
Le comportement d'une partie
de mes collaborateurs
allait vraiment
dans le sens d'attaques.
-Malgré tout,
Suzanne ne fléchit pas,
alors la direction
la convoque à nouveau
et lui propose
une rupture conventionnelle.
-Je m'écroule
toute seule
dans mon coin.
Je ne le montre pas
et je demande
à mettre fin à l'entretien.
Deux jours après,
j'élabore un scénario
pour attenter
à mes jours
et c'est mon...
Excusez-moi.
C'est mon conjoint
qui décide
de m'emmener
chez le médecin traitant et...
Le médecin traitant me dit :
"Vous êtes victime
"de harcèlement moral
depuis deux ans.
"Je fais un retrait immédiat,
"vous ne retournerez plus
dans l'entreprise,
"parce que vous encourez
un risque vital."
Excusez-moi.
C'est encore très douloureux.
-Suzanne est en arrêt maladie
depuis 18 mois.
Un arrêt qui peut se prolonger
trois ans maximum.
Ensuite,
le médecin du travail
la déclarera probablement inapte
à retourner dans cette entreprise,
et elle sera licenciée.
Marielle Dumortier en fait
le constat tous les jours,
la souffrance vécue au travail
s'apparente à une violence
qui nécessite le plus souvent
un suivi psychologique.
-Je suis venue vous voir,
car ça fait un moment
que je ne vous avais pas vue.
Et donc,
je suis suivie...
J'ai...
J'ai donc été suivie
par une psychologue.
-Oui.
-Je ne pense pas revenir
dans mon entreprise.
C'est trop douloureux.
-Hm, il faut que vous retrouviez
la confiance aussi.
Confiance en vous,
car vous avez des compétences,
même si on vous a dit
le contraire.
Evidemment que vous savez faire,
bien sûr.
Ca marche ?
-Ouais.
-Cette souffrance engendre
une remise en question
qui va bien au-delà
de la sphère professionnelle.
-Quand on est
en souffrance
au travail,
les salariés,
ce sont pas
des malades psychiatriques.
Simplement, ce sont des salariés
qui sont déstabilisés
d'une façon
extrêmement profonde.
Ca veut dire que...
Quand on a attaqué
leurs gestes professionnels,
en réalité, on a mis à mal
leur identité profonde,
et c'est tout ce chemin-là
qu'il faut reparcourir avec eux.
-Mais pourquoi certaines difficultés
professionnelles
sont-elles capables
de déstabiliser à ce point
un individu
en remettant en cause
son identité profonde ?
Une raison
serait que les techniques
de développement personnel
et leur injonction à s'accomplir
dans les sphères de la vie
n'ont pas échappé
au milieu de l'entreprise.
C'est la thèse de Thierry Jobard.
Selon lui, sous couvert d'aider
les individus à se sentir mieux,
avec des prêt-à-penser
du genre...
*-"Renouer
avec sa volonté profonde",
"Le bonheur d'être soi",
et celui-là que je viens de trouver,
"Je dope mon narcissisme,
toutes les clés
"pour enfin s'aimer".
-Le développement personnel
aurait en fait un effet pervers
en milieu professionnel,
celui de faire reposer
sur le seul salarié
les dysfonctionnements
de l'entreprise.
*-Les salariés,
on va leur demander
d'être créatifs, de s'impliquer,
de vouloir se réaliser
dans son travail,
de vouloir s'accomplir
dans son travail.
Cet engagement
corps et âme du salarié...
C'est plus simplement son travail
qui compte, c'est sa personne.
Si son travail
est remis en question,
sa personne l'est aussi.
A partir de ce moment-là,
jamais ils ne vont remettre
en question l'organisation,
ou le process
ou les procédures
ou la hiérarchie.
-Pourtant, certains ouvrages
peuvent aussi aider.
Beaucoup évoquent ici
un best-seller du genre,
"Les quatre accords toltèques",
qui édictent
quatre grands principes
de vie.
*-Il y en a un dont je me sers
vraiment régulièrement,
c'est : quand quelqu'un me fait
quelque chose qui me blesse,
je me dis :
"Ne le prends pas pour toi."
Il y a quelque chose comme ça
dans un des quatre accords.
"Ne le prends pas pour toi-même,
c'est sa situation à lui
"qui fait
qu'il te renvoie cette parole."
Donc ça, ça m'aide beaucoup.
*-Oui, mais si vous voulez, il y a
un des autres enseignements
des accords toltèques...
Je ne sais plus la formulation
qui est brillantissime,
et je ne voudrais pas la dénaturer.
C'est...
Alors, attends, nanana...
Que votre parole serait impeccable.
Rires
Voilà, "en entreprise,
que votre parole soit impeccable".
Ca veut dire quoi ? Ca veut dire
que si vous avez un problème,
par exemple, parce que le cas
a été documenté, si vous êtes
victime de harcèlement
pendant des mois et des mois,
et que ça vous détruit,
et que vous voulez en parler
à votre hiérarchie,
il va vous dire : "Eh, attends,
que ta parole soit impeccable."
"Tu ne peux pas parler comme ça,
tu es trop agressive,
"tu laisses parler ton émotion,
il faut le dire de telle façon."
Et qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Eh ben, on est désapproprié
de son propre langage
pour utiliser le langage
de la novlangue néolibérale,
comme ça, on froissera personne,
ça ne changera rien
et la souffrance
de la personne harcelée,
elle sera toujours là.
C'est ça, le problème.
-La crise sanitaire a été
un facteur aggravant
de la souffrance
au travail.
Selon Santé publique France,
la dépression
serait désormais à l'origine
de 40 %
des arrêts de travail.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...